gear inspired by god of war a surprising
connection to predator 2. here's how
prey is rewarding fans on the hunt for
easter eggs
naru and her brother tabe share a close
sibling relationship despite tabe's
apparent affection for his younger
sister he also doesn't seem to have much
faith in her capability as a hunter
though one might see this more as a
protective posture given that he doesn't
want her in harm's way even still
everyone within naru's tribe doubts her
hunting prowess in the film's opening
moments tabe is reminiscing his early
hunting experiences with the family
while naru scopes out a fresh kill tabe
then quickly takes the kill and tells
naru that she was sleeping signaling
that she's hesitant to take her best
shot she tells tabe that she's been
genuinely practicing her hunting
technique and that she's ready to hunt
the big game a mountain lion her brother
questions her with a serious look you
really think you're ready
you want to hunt something that's
hunting you
while the two are completely unaware of
the real threat in the forest it's a fun
bit of foreshadowing for the showdown to
come
there are not a lot of ways this film
could include callbacks or references to
the other films simply because it's a
prequel set at the earliest point in the
franchise's chronology however director
dan trachtenberg and crew clearly saw
moments where they could simply allow
themselves to be inspired by the
predator legacy one such moment occurs
when naru and issei are fleeing the
predator just after their hunting party
first meets the creature in all of its
terrifying glory naru heads into a field
of tall grass and itse grabs her from
his hiding spot and motions for her to
be quiet while silently telling her that
he has eyes on the creature she then
sees the predator's targeting reticle on
itse's forehead realizing that the
predator sees him too she buys itse a
few more seconds of life by causing the
predator to miss his target but of
course the predator runs poor itse down
in the field and guts him this scene is
a direct homage to the moment in the
original predator film that plays out
the same way between dylan and mack mack
believes he's in a prime hiding spot and
quietly tells dylan that he sees the
creature in the trees ahead and is ready
to strike unfortunately for mac the
predator sees him too dylan isn't quick
on the draw like nauru so the predator
does deliver a killing blast to max dome
using his targeting system
when going up against a creature as
horrific as the predator it might seem
like the fight is hopeless naru
witnesses the predator single-handedly
kill a full-grown grizzly bear and then
proceed to lift the beast over its head
in a moment of celebration over the kill
she then sees the aliens systematically
slaughter the most skilled warriors in
her tribe with ease the predator has all
of the advantages for starters the
creature is hulking by nature basic
hand-to-hand combat will almost
certainly end badly for any human
fighter it also has the deadliest
high-tech weaponry in the galaxy for
much of this film the predator remains
cloaked by its light bending technology
making it nearly invisible to the naked
eye alongside its staple cloaking system
claws and spear the predator also has
plenty of deadly gadgets at one point in
the film fur trappers capture nauru and
her brother and tie them to a tree as
bait for the creature the joke's on them
however since the predator ignores the
sibling duo entirely during the chaos of
the moment tabe suggests that he and his
sister can bring it down naru says that
she doesn't think they can kill it tabe
responds if it bleeds
we can kill it if you didn't pick up on
that line then you should definitely
re-watch the original movie the quote is
one of the famous one-liners uttered by
arnold schwarzenegger's dutch in the
original film after being told the
creature hunting his commandos was
injured and leaving blood behind on the
leaves if it bleeds
we can kill it
all of the predator films have one thing
in common the ending always boils down
to a one-on-one fight with the alien
hunter the first film famously pits the
mercenary dutch against the creature the
sequel sees danny glover's mike harrigan
take on the vicious alien in the urban
sprawl of los angeles in predators the
elite commando royce takes on a predator
while stranded on an alien planet 2018's
the predator ends with professional
sniper quinn mckenna as the last man
standing in a fight with a super
predator so naturally prey would
conclude with a head-to-head
confrontation featuring a lone warrior
naru is that lone warrior ultimately she
lures the predator into a trap earlier
in the film she finds herself trapped in
a quick sinking bog to survive she uses
her axe and rope to pull herself out and
during a previous battle she acquired
the predator's mask using that mask she
lures the predator into the bog naru
then mutters under her breath a familiar
line
come on come on come on come on
do it
once the predator fires its weapon the
shot diverts away from nauru because of
the active targeting system of the mask
after a few ricochets the shot returns
to the predator's skull this is another
inspired reference from the original
film where dutch sets a trap for the
predator after being severely injured he
crawls through the mud down into a ditch
that contains a trap that would impale
the creature with spikes if the predator
triggers it dutch goads the hunter into
coming at him yelling that same phrase
over and over
in this film the predator brings some
new deadly toys to play with the alien
race of hunters is known for its vast
array of gadgets and hunting weaponry
each succeeding predator film always
adds something new to the mix when it
comes to the predator's arsenal prey is
no different in fact video game fans
might be intrigued by the clear
inspiration for a couple of the film's
latest additions the predator is
sporting a new shield that unfolds from
its gauntlet if that sounds familiar
then you are likely a fan of the 2018
action adventure game god of war the
game follows kratos a demi-god remnant
of the greek pantheon of deities in
ancient scandinavia he battles the
monstrosities of norse mythology one of
his tools of the trade is a slick shield
that emerges from a gauntlet the god of
war similarities don't stop there naru
uses an axe that she lobs at her prey
with precision however she finds that
recovering her axe expends precious time
on a hunt she affixes a rope to the
weapon so she can recall it with a yank
of her wrist kratos can recall his acts
in the game much like thor can summon
mule near speaking with comicbook.com
dan trachtenberg stated i teased a while
ago that i took inspiration from the
latest god of war video game and those
two things are in the trailer one is his
shield that you see briefly and the
other is not a predator gadget but just
the way that nauru wields her axe she
invents something very cool for that
tomahawk
predator fans might recall the climactic
ending of the original film in which the
predator refuses to die alone after
dutch fatally wounds the alien hunter
the creature arms a bomb on its wrist
gauntlet and begins laughing maniacally
at dutch in a bit of a gotcha moment
dutch barely escapes the blast on foot
as the jungle burns to the ground around
him prey references this moment but
innovates the explosives in the gauntlet
for something a bit new and less
devastating after naru leaves the fur
trappers behind to be eviscerated by the
predator we see a moment where the
hunters find the creature's gauntlet
laying on the ground with a similar
countdown indicator three flying drones
emerge from the gauntlet and the hunters
begin running but it's too late the
little devices hone in on the poor saps
and explode
as the predator makes his way across the
great plains he hunts other earthly
predators in the early moments of the
film we see him kill and skin a
rattlesnake at one point he spies on a
wolf hunting a rabbit after the wolf
lands his mark the predator attacks and
spars with the carnivore unfortunately
for the wolf a sharp set of fangs is no
match for this highly skilled and
heavily armed hunter after charging the
predator the wolf is swiftly gutted the
alien then removes its spine and head in
typical predator fashion in the previous
films we always see the predator
polishing human skulls and creating
trophies out of the people he managed to
kill while we don't get to see this
predator do as much with its human prey
we do witness the predator polishing and
cleaning the wolf's skull in a clear
callback to past movies
as far as movie monsters are concerned
the predator has a legacy and reputation
to uphold the creature is one of the
fiercest in movie history as it tends to
rack up a rather high body count before
finally meeting its demise at the hands
of the film's last remaining hero unlike
its xenomorph contemporaries the
predator doesn't just kill
indiscriminately there are rules it
follows while out on the hunt both
predator and predator 2 established that
the alien hunter doesn't play unfairly
it refuses to harm children anyone that
is unarmed or pregnant women deep shock
when she's alive
i'm picking up fetal heart tones this
woman is pregnant let's move after
making this observation the protagonists
typically remark that the predator finds
no sport in killing something that can't
defend itself whether it's a code of
honor or a true lack of sport the
predator has always abided by that rule
prey shows that this was never any
different centuries ago after nauru
flees the beast while he slaughters the
rest of her hunting party she gets
snagged on a bear trap the predator
approaches her but doesn't end her life
simply because she was incapacitated by
someone else's trap and was not a threat
naru understands this and shares this
observation with her brother tabe later
the predator franchise has often
referenced a greater world outside of
the simple man vs beast conflict
happening on the ground predator 2 blows
the universe of the hunters wide open
with a killer reveal at the tail end of
the film when mike harrigan follows the
predator into the alien's ship he gets
the better of the hunter and slays him
in the predatorship we can see a trophy
case complete with a xenomorph skull of
alien fame even more intriguing is when
all the fallen predators comrades appear
to pay respect to mike for his combat
prowess as a parting gift they give him
a flintlock pistol dated 1715.
it was a cool reveal to demonstrate that
the predators have been visiting and
hunting prey on earth for centuries prey
takes place in 1719 just four years
after the date on the pistol and
predator 2. a flintlock pistol does take
center stage in the third act of the
film one of the injured fur trappers
gives it to naru in exchange for her
help tending to his wounds at the end of
the film after naru slays the predator
she returns to her village and lays the
head of the beast at the feet of the
elders she also tosses them the pistol
upon careful examination we see that the
pistol is inscribed with the name rafael
adollini and the year 1715 this is the
same inscription on the pistol from
predator 2 ultimately tying this film to
the greater predator universe it's quite
possibly the film's coolest easter egg
there is one more detail that many might
miss who don't like sitting through the
credits the first portion of the film's
credits is relayed through a series of
native american drawings recreating the
events of the film as if they were
cemented in history the end scene is
even depicted where naru delivers the
predator's head to her elders one moment
is also shown that wasn't captured in
live action which is a quick drawing of
alien ships descending onto the village
just after nauru's celebratory moment
the predators could be returning to
collect the body of their fallen comrade
which they are known to do or perhaps
they're initiating another hunt one
thing is certain the predators somehow
gain possession of that flintlock pistol
that naru gave to her elders so is a
sequel in order let's hope so
[Music]
you